all right first audience questions of
2018 were starting with Yvette who has a
question about 2018 she writes what will
the major political issues and battles
of 2018 be so there's like micro and
macro to this I think one of the micro
issues is we are eventually going to
hear about the Supreme Court's decision
about the anti-gay cake-baking case and
I think that that's going to be
interesting because it does relate to
the new wave of anti gay activism I told
you and I wasn't the only one saying it
I'm merely saying we discussed when the
Supreme Court ruled that states can no
longer ban same-sex marriage we talked
and were very clear about the reality
that the next frontier in anti LGBT
activism was going to be using so-called
religious freedom to discriminate in
other ways whether it's at jobs or by
businesses whatever else this case is
going to be a really important decision
in terms of the precedent around saying
it is my religiously my constitutionally
promised rights to be able to use my
religion as a guiding pillar
if LGBT as they would call them
lifestyles don't match my beliefs or use
whatever phrasing you want that
resonates with you or with them or
whatever so I think that that's going to
be an interesting decision the midterms
at the macro level these midterms and
midterm elections typically
have particularly low turnout generally
there is a wave although george w bush
didn't experience this in 2002 generally
in the midterms you have a wave where
the party not in the white house except
seats in general midterms have
consequence but not massive consequence
particularly during a president's first
term that could be very different in
2018 these midterms could determine if
there is a door opened for the
impeachment or push for resignation of
Donald Trump will our elected officials
push for it or will they push against it
whether you have a democratic or
republican majority in the House
or Senate gonna be a big factor in that
so I think that these midterms
I hope turnout is high but they actually
could be some of the more consequential
midterms in a long time it's interesting
is that the top political issues of this
year we'll probably be decided by Trump
because whatever policy proposals he's
put forward so last year we think about
healthcare him trying to repeal the
Affordable Care Act right we think about
the tax plan at the very end of the year
yeah maybe this year he will go for
infrastructure maybe he'll focus on the
wall instead I think it's kind of
unclear at this point yeah but it's
largely up to him he has I mean listen
the question is what will the
Republicans make an issue because they
have huge agenda setting power right now
that's part of the power of controlling
the White House and the Senate and the
House of Representatives which is that
not only do you have more than 50% of
the votes you also control the agenda
outside of some very specific procedural
moves that Democrats are sometimes able
to employ depending on the nature of
whatever topic it is they want to take
up in the House or Senate not only do
the Republicans have the majority of the
votes they control the discussion and
that's a major thing and what if there's
another Supreme Court battle - I know
Kennedy was talking about yeah you're
tiring there are quite a few progressive
justices on the court now who are in
their 80s so you never know if they ass
away or what have you or decide to
retire then there's gonna be a battle
for control of the Supreme Court that
would be huge and again this is why the
message is we got a vote we've got a
vote in 2018 we've got to vote them out
very few people vote comparatively
speaking in general in the United States
even fewer people vote in midterms we've
got a vote and we've got to vote them
out